[Music]
by my girlfriend all right we're live
person that was complicated I think this
is live yeah
yes video not one light you know what
thumbs up smash that thumb up what's up
got it for a couple more people to jump
in here what's up everyone
we are live dan I got Seinfeld [ __ ] yeah
man Seinfeld you can do like 199
experience where you go inside there
like police headquarters found Waldo
alright guys so this is my my first time
ever at Comic Con we're gonna get in
line for this detective Pikachu thing
and hopes that we make it to the
Simpsons panel later on but detective
Pikachu is primary that's most important
it's only gonna be this one year all
kinds of craziness going on right now we
don't even have to look good we'll just
wait in line and talk with people for a
little bit yeah take questions
this will be our panel rejects panel how
crazy is it for you guys to be looking
at everything on our end of things so I
just wanted to say look at that
this wanna say first off thank you to
every one of the subscribers because if
it wasn't for you guys we wouldn't have
been a lot of this opportunity I've
never been able to go to comic-con
before oh oh we're gonna we're gonna
have to come okay babe get in like I'm
gonna show them this is handling really
good you know what I gotta get in line
there's lines too crazy where's the
detective Pikachu thing it's like
there's a raw live stream you'll ever
see yeah isn't this Shazam this is where
the detective Pikachu line is it's
craziness this is why I've always wanted
to come here to experience the anxiety
and pain I literally meditated before I
hop onto this also mine we wanted yeah
Kevin Feige was walking around Hall H
apparently so apparently we thought it
might be like oh we could at least go
back to the hotel edit upload film
that's uh that's like a near-impossible
first off the internet is so slow at our
place and job trying to keep you in the
frame - and then what ended up happening
and then yeah just walking back to the
crowds and then going back to the hotel
it just takes way too long and then
ultimately I we found it's going to be a
completely unenjoyable experience and
it's over like you know I'm just gonna
live through this experience and then
eventually we eventually shoot The
Witcher when we get back home maybe
watch that nothing walking dead trailer
apparently that's out and told to us
yeah right right now we're experiencing
the apocalypse it's a great time all we
need is there a bar in the middle we're
those annoying people in the middle of a
crowd live streaming right now
it's just making our way through I'm not
gonna lie I did a we watch the cats
trailer on the road over here so we're
not gonna do reaction to that my oh my
god
we watched it and we were like man that
that looks that looks powerful and then
we can we hop in this way yeah this is
the detective Pikachu line here we go
very experience had to begin to
Detective all the way over there all to
get in this line it's gonna be worth it
look I prefer to do this over the
Simpsons panel yeah Johnny you're the
citizens panel all that fresh season 45
info this is the most unorganized lives
right yeah I really just wanted to come
in on here and tell you guys that nah
come on a photo yeah we got a cable
snaked all the way back to the hotel to
charge it yesterday so Joe Manganiello I
touched him I didn't want to introduce
myself to him because everyone was
looking at him the whole time but I
touched him I saw him dancing on a
sidewalk yes we were at I was up a TV
Guide a fan-favorite panel with my girl
friend and Stephen Amell made a surprise
appearance that was really cool
something I was a wide combination of
like agents of shield yeah take however
you want to say me touching him as a way
out of context as you'd like and roll
with it hopefully makes the papers I'm
not seeing Grace Randolph I'm pretty
sure she's in the East Coast yeah then
we'll be beating her this for detective
Pikachu hmm people love that Pikachu and
keep on going then we're gonna be able
to I mean we're walking the convention
floor I'm gonna do that more tomorrow
because everything's gonna be
say it's town then I'm gonna experience
some Patton went to the penny worth
panel that show looks great
and what else oh yeah the VIP party for
dark web the dark web dark web comic-con
panel went great but yeah when we get
back home we'll watch that Witcher
trailer for two people are demanding our
reaction even though we're both like we
haven't played the game but everyone's
demanding already it'll be fun it'll be
fun yeah I just want to stop